it's
i saw glasses malone tweet something
that the
future west coast hip-hop is very it it
lies a lot on on whether or not it's on
you essentially
i mean i forget what he said i know
she's talking about that i try to sort
through glasses [ __ ]
sports takes and get something good and
he said something about like the future
of west coast music
depends a lot on on me on your success
when you saw that like like that i mean
you know glasses of og out here like
that's a lot of you know that's a lot to
carry a lot to handle especially in my
position but
i just look at it as like
i don't know i'm just grateful you know
at the end of the day like i can't
really
i don't really like to brag or nothing
like i'm i'm humble like i keep
everything not too high not too low
yeah when i see stuff like that it's
just reinsurance for me like i said
earlier
just like damn that's big like g malone
is a legend
shout out to glasses man he's also just
a very very
uh he's like the skip bayless of hip-hop
if you ever want to follow someone on
twitter and want to break your [ __ ]
computer screen just follow glasses
at g malone that's my boy